we routinely go out into the
computational universe to find
algorithms which when we as humans look
at them we say that's really clever
that's you know it's a it's a really
neat thing and it's something where if
there'd been a human creating them we
would have been very impressed by that
humans creativity but actually these
things were just found by searching this
sort of formal abstract universe of
possible programs so i think it's sort
of an interesting question when we look
at different areas of sort of human
endeavor to what extent what we have
found what we create is something that
is is a feature of kind of us as humans
into what it saw what extent it's sort
of what's necessarily out there what one
area I've thought about quite a bit as
mathematics and the question is is the
mathematics that we have today sort of a
a necessary kind of formal structure or
is it something that really is more a
reflection of the particular history of
human mathematics and so one thing that
we can think about is this if we look at
sort of all the mathematics that's been
done mathematics is er is a field of
inquiry where one thinks one starting
from a collection of axioms and then
deriving all these theorems of what's
true about mathematics the complete
axioms for all the mathematics that's
been done in the last however many years
fit on a page or two of something there
in the new kind of science book for
example actually displayed on a couple
of pages so that's sort of the raw
material for all of mathematics there's
a couple pages of axioms from those
axioms about three million or so
theorems have been derived in the
history of mathematics and the question
though is why those axioms why not other
axioms well we can sort of think about
the universe of all possible axioms we
can just imagine kind of enumerated
possible axiom systems that one can
formally consider and we do that and we
can say out of this universe of all
possible axiom systems whether the
axioms that correspond to our particular
mathematics lie and so I know the answer
to that for things like logic for
example I know that logic if you were to
enumerate all possible axiom systems
logic is about the 50,000th axiom system
that you'd find in that enumeration
so realizing that it makes one makes one
think about so why this mathematics and
not some other and what one realizes
it's really the mathematics we have
today is something that is a direct
historical consequence of ideas that
existed in ancient Babylon arithmetic
and geometry and so on that got sort of
generalized to give us the mathematics
we have today and that's the mathematics
that we use to kind of make our
descriptions in physics and do our
engineering and so on what one realizes
is that there's this whole sort of
universe of other possible mathematics
is out there that in fact in many cases
can be much more powerful in describing
things that we see in the natural world
and so on and that forms sort of the
basis for for a lot of New Directions in
science and technology and elsewhere so
in a sense the mathematics that we have
today is is very much it's a it's a
great historical artifact it's probably
if one looks at the history of
civilization mathematics as it exists
today is probably the single largest
artifact in the sense that more hands
have been involved in sort of molding
the particular the intellectual thing
that's been created that than anything
else in history but we have to realize
that it is very much a a human artifact
created from its history not something
that's sort of a necessary feature of
the way that sort of formal systems or
the universe work